We could jokingly say 2 plus 2 equals 5, but this is not actually an equation.
So I'm going to check it off. The reasons it is not an equation is that the
quantities on either side of the equal sign are not actually equal to one
another. We know that 2 plus 2 equals 4, and we know that 4 is not equal to 5.
So this is not a true equation. When you do the same check on this equation
right here. Once again, since 2 plus 2 equals 4, that means we have 4=4, which
is an equation. So we won't check this answer choice. n plus 2 equals n plus 3
is a little bit trickier. Now, what is the problem here? Although I didn't tell
you that this is an answer that you should have selected. The issue is that, no
matter what value you substitute in for n, the two sides of this equation will
never be equal to one another. The right-hand side, that says n plus 3, will
always be 1 larger than the left=hand side.
So for example, if we let n equal zero, we have 0 plus 2 equals 0 plus 3, which
leaves us with 2 equals 3, and that is not true. A similar thing will happen no
matter what number you plug in for n. The same thing is not true of this
equation, 1 plus n plus 1 equals n plus 2. In fact, the opposite is true. No
matter what value we substitute in for n here, this equation will always be
true. This is a special kind of equation that we'll talk about in just a second.